[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar nsf 456 vaccine storage a new
standard detailing requirements for
vaccine cold storage
i am marie stone of lab labroots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific to learn
more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
in addition to submitting questions for
our speaker we encourage you to
participate in two poll questions before
we start the presentation
in order to submit your answer click on
your selection when it is displayed on
your screen
our first poll question is
does your facility will your facility
require
nsf-456 units be purchased for future
vaccine storage
yes
no
unsure
again to make your selection click on
the answer
the question again does your facility
will your facility require nsf 456 units
be purchased for future vaccine storage
we'll leave this up here for a few more
seconds give you time to make your
selection
and then our second poll question is
before this webinar had you heard of nsf
ansi 456
yes
no
unsure
again in order to make your selection
click on your answer
before this webinar had you heard of nsf
ansi 456
yes
no
unsure
we'll give you a few more seconds to
record your answer
thank you for your participation i'd
like to now welcome our speaker chase
hybel senior global product manager
laboratory refrigeration and sample
transport thermo fisher scientific
chase you may now begin your
presentation
thank you
and thank you for having me and thank
you to everyone attending i know these
are crazy times for anyone related to
scientific and healthcare applications
or rather really anyone in general but
um so i really appreciate you taking
this time out of your day during this
discussion we'll dive into a new
standard that was released last year
that impacts the storage of vaccines
very timely release considering
everything that is going on
and while the standard is focused on
vaccine storage the learnings and
recommendations presented really
translate to a broad array of scientific
and clinical cold chains
to summarize what we'll be going through
today we'll start off with the new era
of vaccines we're going through what the
current recommendations are for vaccine
storage within the u.s
the
standards that have now been released
and we'll go into detail on those and
then what solutions we provide and other
considerations you should take
when working with cold storage units
so first let's jump in starting with a
new era of vaccines and more to the
point the importance of a robust cold
chain
vaccines as we knew them have
fundamentally changed in the last two
years and their importance while always
being high have become more pronounced
in the public psyche
access to an availability of mrna
vaccines was not available less than two
years ago
they really
none have been commercially available or
launched now there's a large pipeline of
new mrna-based vaccines and therapies
making their way to the market
this change in vaccine technology
technology also drove a change in how
they are produced stored and managed
throughout the cold chain
the new biology also drew drove new
temperature profiles for cold chain
while an ebola vaccine used negative 70
celsius in the last decade
focus in this ultra cold space was never
broadly given nor commonly used
for that matter before these covid
vaccines even a negative 20 celsius
storage temperature was not mainstream
as only a few vaccines on the market
today require it
there has been a lot of work this last
year and a half by manufacturers to
supply these cold chains with the proper
equipment to transform and expand the
cold chain but that statement in and of
itself implies there was proper
equipment for these cold chains
and more specifically at the end site
storage locations
proper equipment standards that helped
ensure the units could store those
vaccines at the right temperatures to
ensure efficacy
they didn't exist
when there is a breakdown in that cold
chain and temperatures exceed the bounds
prescribed by the manufacturer
that is when vaccine wastage occurs
even with all the scrutiny today around
covet vaccine wasted still occurs the
cdc requires all organizations that
administer the vaccines to report the
number of vaccine doses
that were quote unquote unused spoiled
expired or wasted as required by the
relevant jurisdiction
the cdc also asked states to describe
their wastage monitoring method during
the distribution planning process
vaccine providers such as pharmacies and
hospitals are supposed to provide data
on wasted doses to their state health
agencies which then send the information
to the cdc
like many parts of the initial vaccine
rollout that didn't go as perfectly as
to plan as it could have
and that isn't a criticism to the agency
or companies at all you know what what
has been accomplished
over the last year and a half by all
those involved has been nothing short of
miraculous
state by state
reporting requirements vary and are not
reliably communicated vaccine providers
even when the rules are clear they are
not regularly enforced nor the numbers
reported to the public
early in the rollout within the u.s the
cdc recorded about 200 000 wasted dosage
three months into the country's effort
to vaccinate the masses
of those one retail pharmacy chain was
responsible for nearly half
while another 21
and we must remember at the time
vaccines were hard to come by and
everyone was every single one of them
was needed
the likely overall number is much higher
this is since while there's a
requirement for reporting there isn't a
penalty or wasn't at the time for not
reporting
putting this into a global context for
all vaccines based on an early study
conducted by the world health
organization or the who
it is estimated that approximately 50
percent of all vaccines are wasted
yearly
that is an extraordinarily high number
that if applied to the early coveted
rollout would have been detrimental
especially as some more develop
some of the more developing countries
are even today struggling to get any
meaningful supply
now there's a lot of reasons for that
wastage
expired vaccines
is a big part of it but another part of
it is and a leading cause of the wastage
is improper storage during the vaccine
cold chain
exposure to temperatures outside of
those prescribed by the drug
manufacturers guidelines causes vaccines
to lose efficacy
and they therefore must be disposed of
something to keep in mind when talking
about vaccine wastage is it isn't just a
financial impact but also a public
health impact the longer it takes to
vaccinate the populace and to achieve
her or
higher immunity levels
the higher the rate of infection
hospitalization than death will stay and
that's for any
endemic pandemic regardless if it's code
one of
other factor that is hugely important
especially with these vaccines is that
with wastage or ineffective dosage being
given the more negatively impacted
public confidence becomes
justified or not there's a tremendous
amount of distrust skepticism or
wait-and-see approach being taken
regarding these vaccines and any
breakdown in the process related to them
can fuel that more
for these reasons making sure vaccine
cold chain is as strong as possible is
crucially important
so we talked about wastage in the cdc's
requirements for reporting it at least
you know versus
via the emergency youth authorization
for covad but now let's review the
current recommendations for vaccines in
the u.s and see how they mitigate
against some of this wastage
so currently the uscdc only provides
recommendations for the handling and
storage of vaccines
not standards not regulations but
recommendations
now there's some requirements for
participation in programs like the
vaccines for children program but even
those don't look at the equipment
themselves in any meaningful way
these recommendations are compiled into
a single document that is updated and
published yearly and is called the
vaccine storage and handling tool kit
it reflects best practices for vaccine
storage and handling and the 2021 tool
kit
was designed is designed to help
healthcare providers find information
they need quickly and easily the
beginning chapters address the three
main elephant elements of an effective
cold chain
a well-trained staff
reliable storage and temperature
monitoring equipment and accurate
vaccine inventory management
it does not however
go into detail on what an appropriate
vaccine refrigerator and freezers are
the only real criteria is that it not be
a dormitory style or bar style combo
unit it's a pretty low bar
from a temperature storage
recommendation the cdc does provide two
ranges frozen which is negative 15 to
negative 50 celsius and refrigerated
which is 2 to 8 celsius
but given no guidelines on how that
values to be term
be determined other than to have a
single digital data logger
with the features listed on the screen
independent probe detachable it can be
calibrated uh low battery indicator just
very rudimentary
recommendations
overall
though there was no standard today in
the u.s or then in the u.s for what a
vaccine cold storage should be
and when i say that what a unit should
be i mean
how is the unit designed
what's the unit's performance
what supporting documentation does it
have to support the application of
storing vaccines
and we'll go into more and more detail
when we talk about the standard itself
on each of those points
if we put this into the lens of today's
code vaccines we must consider what is
written in the emergency youth
authorizations and the playbooks
provided by the cdc and the drug
manufacturers themselves
the eua or emergency youth
authorizations and cdc playbook
guidelines for example for the moderna
vaccine only provide a temperature range
and duration for them at each
temperature
i.e negative 20 storage for x amount of
days or months or weeks
two to eight for x amount of days and
room temperature for x amount of hours
but they don't give you how that is to
be determined those ranges
or how they should be monitored
so we have to rely upon
what's written in the in the toolkit
[Music]
so and as we saw that was just a single
probe located in the cabinet that's
giving a
generalized indication of what the
temperature is within the refrigerator
or freezer
that leaves a tremendous room for how
the refrigerator and freezer is actually
performing because not all places within
a refrigerator or freezer are the same
temperature
it also again leaves a huge room for
interpretation of can i use single door
double door does it need to have a
display
no display alarms of any kind does it
have to have access ports to run those
data probes through
it could it be auto or manual defrost is
there a time that's allowed outside of
those temperature ranges to accommodate
door openings or defrost
you know recommended performance etc etc
and why is this important
and why
may this be a problem
if you remember that most basic
recommendations of a single data logger
with a weighted probe
placed in the cabinet doesn't specify
where with a specific uncertainty degree
and reading which i didn't mention at a
wide reading interval of maybe as little
as once every 30 minutes
on the screen you will see an example of
a temperature map of a basic commercial
grade basic lab grade refrigerator
most of us would assume a refrigerator
is a refrigerator and should hold
product well above freezing
and below a reasonably warm temperature
that is not the case
at all
not all refrigerators and freezers are
created equal
some are designed to store food which
can be much warmer or white with a wider
range or industrial applications medical
applications some are for chromatography
applications there are many different
shape sizes flavors of units in the
market and as a result
they have different temperature
performances within them
and not all units can meet a two to 8 or
negative 15 to negative 50 performance
but what is that performance
so if we get back to the example the
cabinet that i show here on the screen
was mapped with 25 featherweight
open-air thermocouples and operated in a
controlled 20c ambient environment
steady state
no door openings and allowed to fully
stabilize
very happy with its environment in use
so we would think it should be at its
top performance and maybe it is
but is that good enough for vaccines
the other red squares every single point
within this cabinet went below the
recommended lower range of 2c
and most of them even went below
freezing
but look at the average values all
around 3 to 5c
if i had a basic weighted data logger
reading once every 30 minutes i would
most likely never or rarely know that my
vaccines are constantly being subjected
to freezing temperatures
leading to vaccines that have lost
partial or complete efficacy
and this is without even opening the
door we can also see here temperatures
that are close to 8c
which means as soon as i open that door
and warm air goes in and displaces that
cold air i'm most likely going to have
pockets within my refrigerator that
exceed 8c for a certain period of time
again leading to the opposite end of the
spectrum problem of
vaccines that have been subjected to
warm temperatures
so
that's now all changing
and that is thanks to a new nsf standard
published last year
first who is the nsf
not to be confused with the national
science foundation
manufacturers regulators and consumers
look to nsf international for the
development of public health standards
and certification programs that help
protect the world food water consumer
products and environment
accredited by the american national
standards institute or ansi nsf has
developed over 80 currently active
voluntary met american national
standards under the scope of public
health safety environment and
sustainability assessment
nsf ansi standards are developed through
a public process that ensures balanced
input from industry representatives
public health regulatory officials and
user consumer representatives
the nsf mark is in
insurance that the product has been
tested by one of the most respected
independent certification organizations
in existence today it is valued by
consumers manufacturers retailers and
regulatory agencies worldwide
so
the nsf viewed that there was a gap in
standards for vaccines within the u.s we
just went through what those some of
those gaps were
and as a result they put together a
multi-institution committee whose goal
was to define a set of performance
standards for vaccine refrigerators and
freezers to help providers select the
best products to minimize vaccine
wastage
the committee called the nsf joint
committee on vaccine storage
includes representatives from the cdc
nist state health department
immunization programs non-profit
organizations and vaccine storage
equipment manufacturers including
representatives from thermo fisher
scientific
this council of about 20 individuals has
been working on the standard which has
gone through repeated public comment
rounds since 2015.
and even now that the standard is
launched that committee will continue
and
and and
for
foreseeable future
to meet on this standard to see if any
additional recommendations
or changes are needed
to conform to make the standard better
or to conv conform to new trends in the
market related to vaccines
based on an analysis of data from real
life usage within clinics pharmacies and
vaccinations vaccination sites the
committee created a new standard
nsf-456 vaccine storage
to the point it is a standard
not a regulation
not a requirement but many domestic and
global regulatory bodies accreditation
entities organization public health
departments look to standards like these
to create their
own mandatory or recommended guidelines
all to do their best to mitigate against
risk
so while your organization might not
have this as a standard requirement
today
that's generally because it's so early
in the release of the standard
as manufacturers cold storage
manufacturers
certify their products and more are
available on the market and it's easier
to procure and have the choices that
your organization needs
you will start seeing those
recommendations
start becoming more of requirements
from organization to organization or
accreditation body to accreditation body
now the standard itself covers a lot of
missing pieces to properly establish a
proper cold storage unit for vaccines
now let's dive into the actual standard
its overall goal is that
it will create help vaccine
administrators choose a storage unit
that has been certified to stay within
proper temperature
to ensure the safety and efficacy of the
vaccines and ultimately the public
or more simply plainly the standard is
intended to define the appropriate
criteria for storage units used to store
vaccines
elements include an audit checklist and
criteria for grading that apply to
manufacturers of storage units and the
standard includes critical elements of
quality management system for proper
vaccine storage
the standard is broken down into two
temperature ranges refrigerated two to
eight
b and freezers negative fifteen to
negative fifty
both look at the same aspects but for
two different temperature ranges
now you might ask at the beginning of
this we saw that some of these coveted
vaccines physio in particular require
ultra low storage temperature negative
70 celsius or
so and this was a new part of the cold
chain within the last year
where the council has been working on
this standard for years
it is also a temperature that may
continue to evolve warmer and it hasn't
yet and and all indications in the short
term is that it won't
but for these reasons and others the
council did not expand the scope to
include the ultra low range there was a
view with everything going on in the
world that these standards needed to
come out to protect that negative 2 or
plus 2 to negative 8 range and negative
15 to negative 50 range
the grouping within the standard within
my general terms
fall into three buckets
design thermal performance and
documentation
grouping one around
is design not all units are designed
from a form fit and function standpoint
to store vaccines so the standard looks
at things simply like doors lids and
closures do they fit well and do they
self close
all units that are sold today as vaccine
storage units
really
have self-close features or basic
door and lid closures that you would
expect
barriers is another big part of the
standard do the units prevent users from
putting vaccines in places that don't
meet the temperature performance
requirements we're going to go into this
one a little bit more detail in a few
slides here
um
and then temperature controls
things like is it being automatic can it
be adjusted can i actually set the
temperature and adjust the temperature
temperature displaying alarms this is a
long one but some basic pieces are that
they are immediate audible visual alarms
if the unit goes outside of the
prescribed range
and alarms cannot be silenced longer
than 15 minutes for refrigerators in 30
minutes for freezers now why might that
be important
is if somebody in the facility
accidentally or not accidentally hits
the snooze button for the alarm
that they don't forget or the
appropriate parties
don't miss that that alarm has occurred
so they can take the corrective actions
that are needed
and then temperature monitor monitoring
you know are there accommodations for
independent monitoring using a
third-party device
most healthcare facilities most labs use
independent monitoring systems that use
independent probes well a lot of those
facilities also route those probes
through the door gasket
that creates an access for air to exit
and enter the cabinet warm air to
displace cold air and will impact the
overall performance with inside the
cabinet so
does the device itself the refrigerator
freezer have access ports so you don't
have to do that and create that
potential risk
for ice to build up or an air egress to
be created to impact performance
the next grouping is around thermal
performance
units are tested under a very specific
test procedure and conditions
for example they're about
in a space that's 22 c plus or minus a
degree and a half within a specific um
humidity range 20 to 60 rh
and using measurement accuracy of test
equipment being you know plus or minus a
half a percent as well as many others
and they utilize specifically weighted
thermocouples that mirror the weighting
of a vaccine vial so
as i mentioned before the cdc and others
didn't have a recommendation for how
those probes were being weighted for
those digital data loggers
well now we're doing a representation of
what the temperature is in the cabinet
using weighting of a probe that mirrors
what a vaccine vial would actually
encounter
and these probes are placed
strategically throughout the entire
defined usable space that is this that
in that usable
space is determined using a specific
criteria
and then the tests are repeated for a
loaded and unloaded cabinet to show how
that impacts performance
a lot of manufacturers
and facilities do predominantly only
unloaded cabinets
and they're surprised when they're doing
their their thermal performance studies
and a lot of people are surprised to see
how much that changes once they put
actual product into the cabinet that's
for a couple reasons one the product
creates a thermal mass stabilizing the
internal temperature to a degree
but more importantly from a negative
side they could block airflow within the
cabinet potentially creating colder or
warmer spots within it
so it's important as this standard shows
to do temperature mapping on a loaded
cabinet as well
and there are essentially three tests
performed per temperature range there's
a closed door test which is simply do
all points stay at all times within the
allowed range during the test there's
you cannot exceed those
that temperature 2 to 8 or negative 15
to negative 50 during that close to door
test however with one caveat there is
accommodation for auto defrost
functionality which allows 15 minutes to
recover
time back to the upper bound of the
acceptable temperature range or
15 minutes to get back to 8c or 15
minutes to get back to negative 15c
then there's a short door opening test
this is a three hour test of openings
occurring every 10 minutes
so high use situation that it's
mirroring and those doors are open
two minutes to two seconds to open the
door four seconds for it to be open and
two seconds to close it and that short
door test that first part is followed by
a secondary short door test
that's an hour long
doing that same eight second door
opening but it's every five minutes so
it's mirroring somebody going in and out
and retrieving a dose every five minutes
high use situation
and during this test the cabinet needs
to stay within the bounds as well
so not only when the door is closed but
also when the door is being opened
repeatedly the unit has to stay within
those bounds now if we think back to
that
commercial grade unit
even when the door was closed and not
opened the unit didn't stay within the
bounds so you can imagine once a door
was opened like in this test it would
have no shot
of being
able to stay within those valves nearly
anywhere near within those bounds
and then the third test is a long door
opening test
this test happens every
after 15 minutes or so after the last
short don't test to let the unit recover
and it lasts for three minutes so that
big door or small door or whatever size
it is is opened and left open for three
minutes that's it
try to sit and just stare at a [ __ ] for
three minutes
that is a long time um
when you're retrieving or loading
product so it's looking at the extreme
use case again
then all points in the cabinet have to
recover back below 8c
or below negative 15c
within 15 minutes so it doesn't give
them a very long window to to get all
the way back
but it does allow the cabinet to get
warmer than those bounds for that three
minute period
the two door opening tests were designed
to mimic
typical use within a clinic it was found
that during routine use door openings
are approximately eight seconds long but
they have a very high frequency
this is typical dosage retrieval the
longer test mimics the bulk loading of
product into the cabinets which happens
much less frequently but the duration is
much longer
now i mentioned earlier that the test
accommodates for auto defrost
there are some that shy away from auto
defrost functionality because they
perceive that the odd that the defrost
process can greatly impact product
temperature in the cabinet
but
like i said earlier about refrigerators
not all defrost freezers are created
equal
what we see in this test method and
historically gathered data
door openings have a far greater impact
on cabinet and product temperature than
the defrost cycle of high performance
units designed for the storage of
vaccines
this standard helps to highlight and
reinforce that point
not to go into the nitty-gritty of how
an auto defrost freezer works but
the whole cabinet isn't
defrosting all your product isn't being
warmed to
you know positive temperatures to remove
that ice
it's only the refrigeration system the
evaporator deck that is allowed to warm
itself
and where cabinet temperature doesn't
change dramatically and product
temperature itself
really only changes a few degrees at
most
so the last section here is
documentation
and you'd be surprised what might and
might not come with a refrigerator and
freezer
so what this standard looked at is one
the big one the manual
and updating it to show where
third-party probes could be routed how
often calibration should be done and
other things around proper use
of the unit and what it is intended for
labeling
the standard now requires usable space
to be indicated
and where
third-party test label certification
be present on the unit itself i.e saying
this unit has actually been certified
for the standard
and then calibration certificates shall
be provided with units and be kept on
record with suppliers
not all refrigerators and freezers are
calibrated at the manufacturing sites
before leaving and i would say
even though all of these units are now
calibrated to meet this standard
or units that do meet the standard
certified to it are calibrated
i would still recommend doing your own
calibration
when units arrive because
things could change during shipment or
units could be sat in storage for a
period of time or
um you might have a different
calibration standard than what is used
by the manufacturer i.e you cannot
calibrate the center point mass or to
where your alarm probe is or something
else
so i still even though these are now
coming calibrated
you should still do your own calibration
now there's far more detail to what the
standard looks at then i have time but
there are two sections i want to review
a little bit more in detail and that's
performance and barriers
so first off
performance
on these graphs you can see what the
results of a test protocol look like for
both a refrigerator and freezer both
unloaded and loaded
the test starts off in steady state with
the doors closed goes to the short door
test
in two phases and then the long door
test
you can see on a unit properly designed
and certified to the standard
that the temperature stays well within
the two to eight limits for
refrigerators
as well
that the door open openings do have an
impact but they're not large
and when the cabinet is loaded it stays
even tighter between those lines
thermal mass buffer is essentially what
the cdc was attempting to achieve with
their recommendations by having water
bottles placed around the walls and
storing product in the middle and that's
how loose the standard was for this or
the recommendation was for the from the
cdc
if you look through that toolkit they'll
actually if you're using a standard home
goods refrigerator they'll tell you to
fill the walls or line the walls with
water bottles
to replicate a unit that should be
designed for this purpose
now for the freezers you can see that in
addition to door openings there was also
an auto defrost event
even with that process in the middle of
the door openings the unit stayed below
negative 15 limit again a sign of a
purpose-built unit
in each section of those four total
tests you can see the impact the user
and conditions have on the unit to
maintain temperature
from some being minimal impact first
phase of the door openings especially
when loaded to major impacts like the
three minute door opening that large
spike there at the end
but you can see for the freezers in a
loaded freezer that three minute door
opening
at no point in the cabinet doesn't even
exceed the negative 15
limit
a properly designed unit
now there will be
other products that are certified
to
the nsf standard or broad array
that might have wider performance but
still meet the standard let's say in
that first and the first short door
opening section
that they might just get to
just below 8c or they might just get
just above 2c
now what does that mean
they meet the standard and they pass the
standard
but
any additional stress or reduction of
performance over time
[Music]
increases that risk that you might
exceed those boundaries
so finding a unit that not only meets
the design intent and is certified
to the standard
is important but finding one that has
larger barriers
thermal bearings performance barriers
away from those limits
is going to reduce your risk even more
over time
so the next part why barriers why
why did the rec standard recommend
barriers be placed into the units and
what does barriers mean
in a refrigerator freezer
not all points in the cabinet are the
same temperature
and all points fluctuate to a degree
in order to make sure vaccines aren't
put in places within the cabinet that
exceed the limits in the standards
mandates
that area
be blocked
block could be in the form of a physical
barrier a defined barrier and in
combination an indicated area
this could be as simple as having
borders on your baskets or shelves that
prevent product from touching the walls
or as prohibitive as a cage or something
blocking that entire area
if we look at this for
for the freezer example
now again this is a commercial grade
freezer not specifically designed for
vaccine storage
we can see some stay above the negative
15 limit but others don't
this is done with outdoor openings so we
know this unit will probably struggle to
maintain above negative 15 in other
places but for this example let's
pretend it ran the whole test and got
this performance
in this case to pass the standard the
top shelf would probably need to be
blocked off completely to ensure
vaccines weren't stored there
so the manufacturer would design some
method to prevent that
that's going to be an immediate
indication that this unit was not
designed for the storage of vaccines
when you go out on the market to choose
a freezer it'll be important to
understand how much actual space is left
for you to use traditionally
manufacturers would just use the entire
volume of the inner cabinet
as their capacity
well
that's
now the standard has them actually
defined well where can product actually
be placed to give you a much better
understanding of how much storage
capacity you really do have
for this unit if certified as a customer
i know that
i would know that the space has been
limited
but would also
want to look at the data to make sure
knowing my own usage type let's say i'm
a high usage
and i'm in a warm ambient conditions
that this unit is borderline at negative
15 at every point so if i'm having usage
facility
my door openings would probably take me
past these limits pretty frequently
meaning i should probably move on and
pick a different unit that will stay
well above that warm alarm limit the
same is true for refrigerators as well
all of these points and recommendations
can easily be transferred to other
applications in the lab or healthcare
space
so
a few further considerations
um and best practices to look at
because the standard
only covers a certain amount of things
it doesn't cover how users actually use
it and how they should maintain their
product so
how you use your equipment can greatly
impact their performance
they're made to handle everyday life
or ours are
for real-world situations however you
still want to be prescriptive with door
openings minimize them minimize the
frequency have a system of inventory
management so you know where things are
pay attention to what the unit is
telling you a lot of units have
indicators for something that may be
going wrong outside of just temperature
performance
or maybe it's running a little harder
than or a little bit louder um you know
make sure you're listening to what the
unit is telling you
make use of any of those onboard
capabilities as well and consolidate
your cargo each vial is its neighbor's
best friend from a thermodynamic
perspective
and then a little tlc goes a long way
um
you know follow the recommendations in
the user manual clean the filters remove
excess frost or ice if it starts to
accumulate you know consider warranty
upgrades or service plans to maximize up
time
and then always have contact information
handy for your service provider when and
if something does go wrong
and then lastly from a recommendation
standpoint
i
recommend a lot of people recommend
organizations require it but it's always
something good to look at
for having remote monitoring systems as
part of your risk mitigation strategy
it's going to help with sample safety
and security it's going to make your
workflows more efficient and it's going
to help with ascent management and cost
savings in the long run
you know it's going to reduce risk and
gain operational effect efficiencies
now we've gone through a lot in this 40
minutes or so
um
the new era of vaccines
wastage
what the cdc recommends what the new
vaccine storage requirement or
recommendations are from and standards
are from the nsf
some little tlc guidelines and
recommendations but let's go and look at
what some of the solutions are out there
now that meet this standard
and how they improve protection
so thermoscientific
has the tfx line which is purpose built
for critical storage you know luckily at
thermal fissure we've kept the
protection of vaccines in mind while we
innovate we've been for many many years
been selling into the clinical
healthcare space for the purposes of
vaccines a lot of people remember the
old jewett brand
and that is why the thermo tsx series of
high performance refrigerators and
freezers are purpose built to store
critical products like vaccines that are
sensitive to temperature variations
this series is intended to meet the
standards and over 35 models and
configurations are currently certified
to it
we look closely at the temperature
performance in all parts of the usable
space in the cabinets when we design
this line we go beyond actually what the
standard recommends for performance
and while some manufacturers publish
performance data the methodology used to
generate the data are often inconsistent
which could lead to an improper
understanding of a product's
capabilities that is why it is crucial
to understand the meaning and test
methodology behind thermal performance
data including that of the tsx
refrigerators and freezers you should
ask any of your representatives from any
of your manufacturers for more detailed
testing and performance data
the tsx series
while it's one part of our portfolio
we're going to continue to look at
expanding that and while this is our our
flagship line that delivers low energy
it's energy star certified has the act
label for sustainability
is very quiet best performance and has a
long reliability and covered by a
10-year warranty there are other
products within the portfolio that we
are looking to move towards this
standard as well
and you will see from other
manufacturers that
more and more product being
brought to the market
um but there are many products available
today that are called vaccine storage
that
do not meet the standard set by nsf
for this reason again it's important to
have these discussions with your cold
storage providers now to understand
their plans in supporting your ongoing
need to properly protect the vaccines
you store
and then
the last point that i want to cover
before we wrap here is
you should also consider
a size to fit your need
not all spaces need the same
size unit
and not all units of the same series or
the same manufacturer
will perform the same depending on how
you load them
so it's important to find units that
meet your your
your use case so if you're an endpoint
storage and you only go through you know
a couple dozen vaccine dosage a day
you don't need what your distribution
hub is using
that they're processing thousands of
vaccines a day sending those out to the
various
pharmacies healthcare facilities or so
forth
and why this is
also important and to understand is
finding a unit that will not only meet
your capacity needs today
but also
meet those that are needed for when
there are fluxes in demand there's a
next round of boosters or it's flu
season or whatever it may be you can
accommodate that with oh without
overfilling your unit
because as i mentioned earlier if you
overfill a unit and block that airflow
more you're going to impact the
performance within that unit potentially
creating warm or cold spots
conversely if you have a unit that's
just running empty all the time
because you've gotten a unit that's way
too big one you're wasting space in your
facility two you probably wasted a
little bit of capital budget
and three
your unit is going to perform wider
because it doesn't have that thermal
mass
by volume ratio to keep the cabinet more
stable so just make sure to select the
product that most closely aligns to your
volume needs
and with that
i want to say thank you and i'll pass it
back
and i believe we'll go through some q a
thank you chase for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the bottom right of your screen we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for let's get started our
first question is
are ultra cold temperatures like
negative 70 celsius covered in the
standard
thanks and
like i mentioned no not today and not
from the initial release of the standard
because of the need and desire to get
this standard on the market to have the
most benefit it could it could during
these trying times
however
as i also mentioned these standards
continue to evolve
and over time
there may be standards
a revision of this standard that would
look at that and look at those
temperatures
all right
next question
is this a mandate or requirement what if
i don't use an nsf 456 unit in my
facility
right so today it's not a mandate or
requirement
from a federal or most state levels
they're not going to
the cdc has not come out and said that
thou must use nsf 456 units for the
storage of vaccines
however
the cdc
was a member of this body
of this council
and helped develop these recommendations
so
could it be one day maybe potentially
could it be one day for the
participation of programs like vaccines
for children
potentially
but
more realistically the short-term
requirements are actually going to come
from organizations themselves that are
looking to reduce risk and what do i
mean by reduced risk
if you have a
batch of vaccines that
is exceeds the point
that you have to discard because of
improper storage
and you see that you are using a
non-nsf-456 or
non-vaccine designed unit
it opens the door
from
a risk standpoint of
you know fingers being pointed of not
being using the proper unit for that
that application whether that be from
insurance standpoint
litigation standpoint or whatever it may
be
so people you will see people start
adopting these standards to reduce that
risk as much as possible
all right thank you
next question
if i have an older version of something
that is now certified to the standard
does that mean my older one meets the
standard
unfortunately no so it the um
most likely most manufacturers have
changed minor things to meet the
standard we
not all did we didn't have to for most
or actually any of our products
however
certification is only for
once
units are
audited
the factory has been audited the
manufacturing process the documentation
the performance has been tested so it's
only newly manufactured units that
quote-unquote are certified to that now
as i mentioned this is not a regulation
requirement saying you have to go out
and and use
nsf only products so
if you are using models that are of the
older version that now do meet the
standard that at least gives you the
comfort and knowing that the units that
you're using today
should mean it from a performance
standpoint and that you those should be
on should not be on your short list for
units that you should be replacing
if you're wanting to to reduce your risk
or use units that are purpose-built for
the storage vaccines
all right thank you it looks like we
have time for one more question
why do some vaccine manufacturers
recommend not using frost free freezers
yeah this is an interesting one early on
in the roll out well
backing up a little bit
there's things called manual and auto
defrost freezers they're kind of
to a large degree self-explanatory
manual defrost freezers
you have to manually defrost they have
ice buildup on the wall or shelves over
time and you have to
unplug them and defrost them auto
defrost freezers in contrast you don't
have to do that the ice removal is
mitigated through the refrigeration
system
routinely by itself
now
why is that why do some
vaccine manufacturers today not
historically but today
have fear of frost free and it's for the
very reason that the standard
one of the very reasons this standard
was created
because people frost free or auto
defrost is a broad term that can be
applied to home good units
commercial grade units and and
scientific and metal grade units where a
home good unit
that auto defrost process
like your home unit could swing you into
very wide temperature ranges potentially
above zero and that's why you see it in
your home
refrigerator freezer combo unit you
might get ice build up on your ice cream
or produce or whatever that you have in
your freezer well that's the process of
a product going through extreme
temperature where the moisture is being
pulled out of the product
evaporating
and then reconstitute re-freezing on the
surface
well in a purpose-built auto defrost
unit you're not going to see that
but to be as safe as possible
and so
because the standard didn't exist
those manufacturers shied away from
using auto defrost freezers in fear that
people might use home good or commercial
grade auto defrost freezers but
traditionally vaccine freezers
have been auto defrost
or those purpose built for the storage
vaccines and they have a
huge benefit of
auto defrost freezers have much better
door open recovery time and uniformity
overall thank you chase do you have any
final comments for our audience
i
just this i would say thank you again
for taking the time to get on this i
know
it's again a very busy
um chaotic time if you do have any
questions offline that you want to send
i am happy to to talk more on this topic
or or any other healthcare scientific
cold storage topics
but yeah thank you
well thank you again chase for your time
today in your important research we
would also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye
you